MARIA: WELCOME BACK THIS MORNING
THE CHINA CHALLENGE THE FBI
REVEALING THIS WEEK THE CHINA
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED STATES
WAS SECRETLY RECRUITING
SCIENTIST TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE GOVERNMENT XI JINPING.
BILL BARR WHAT HE TOLD ME LAST
WEEK AND ABOUT THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY AMBITION.
>> THEY WANT TO BE THE LEADER IN
ALL THE FUTURE TECHNOLOGIES TO
DOMINATE THE ECONOMY.
SO WHAT IS AT STAKE IS THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN
WHETHER WE CAN CONTINUE TO BE
THE TECHNOLOGICAL LEADER OF THE
WORLD.
MARIA: SENATOR TOM COTTON IS A
REPUBLICAN FROM ARKANSAS, HE
SOUNDED THE ALARM ABOUT CHINA ON
THIS PROGRAM IN FEBRUARY AND HE
JOINS ME ONCE AGAIN.
IT’S GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU’VE
INTRODUCED THE LET’S START WITH
THE NEW IMAGERY THAT WE HAVE
WHICH SHOWS THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY MILITARIZING AT
THE INDIAN BORDER.
CHINA, YOU HAVE SAID AND OTHERS
HAVE SAID IS USING THE COVID
PANDEMIC AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GAIN MORE GROUND, CAN YOU TELL
ME ABOUT IT?
TOM: THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
IS CERTAINLY USING THE PANDEMIC
TO ASSERT CLAIMS AND TAKE VERY
AGGRESSIVE ACTION AGAINST ALL OF
ITS NEIGHBORS, GO AROUND THE
HORN, YOU STARTED IN INDIA,
CHINA HAS INVADED INDIA
COMMONALITY VIRUS AND KILLED 20
INDIAN SOLDIERS, AND HONG KONG
THEY PASS LEGISLATION THAT
VIOLATES THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMITMENT TO PEOPLE HONG KONG
AND IT WILL TURN HONG KONG INTO
THE SAME KIND OF POLICE STATE
THAT MAINLY CHINA IS.
THE SOUTH CHINA SEA THEY TAKE AN
AGGRESSIVE ACTION OTHER PARTNERS
LIKE THE PHILIPPINES, MALAYSIA,
VIETNAM, THEY REPEATEDLY INVADED
THE AIRSPACE IN RECENT WEEKS OF
TAIWAN IN THIS PAST WEEK THEY
TAKE AGGRESSIVE ACTION AGAINST
JAPAN, THE EAST CHINA SEA, CHINA
IS BECOMING MORE AGGRESSIVE THAN
EVER THAT’S WHITE SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE SUPPORT OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS AND WE MAKE IT CLEAR TO
CHINA, WE WILL NOT TOLERATE THIS
ACTION, WE WILL COMPETITION TO
REMAIN PEACEFUL BUT THE WAY THAT
THAT HAPPENS IS TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT WE STAND WITH THOSE
PARTNERS AND ALLIES.
>> THE PENTAGON REVEALED THAT
THERE ARE MORE THAN 20
COMPANIES, CHINESE MILITARY
COMPANIES OPERATING INSIDE THE
UNITED STATES, THEY ARE DOING
JOINT VENTURES, COMPANIES,
GETTING MONEY FROM THE CAPITAL
MARKETS, HOW IS THIS POSSIBLE
THAT WE HAVE SO MUCH COMPANIES
IN OUR OWN CAPITAL MARKETS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY UNDERMINING
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> UNFORTUNATELY IT REFLECTS
LONG-STANDING BUREAUCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT INDIFFERENCE THAT
CHINA POSES, THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE TO ITS CREDIT PRODUCED A
LIST OF CHINESE COMPANIES THAT
ARE CONTROLLED BY OR AFFILIATED
WITH THE PEOPLE LIBERATION ARMY,
THAT’S BEEN A REQUIREMENT IN THE
LAW SINCE 1999, IT WAS ONLY WHEN
I AND A FEW OTHER LEGISLATORS
BROUGHT IT TO THE DEPARTMENT’S
ATTENTION THAT THEY RESEARCH THE
QUESTION AND PUBLISH THE LIST.
IT’S AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT CHINA
CALLS A LOOK CIVIL MILITARY FUSI
CUTTING-EDGE CIVILIAN COMPANIES
AS FRIENDS TO INCREASE THEIR
MILITARY TECHNOLOGY EVEN IN
COMPETITIVE COMPANIES LIKE THE
UNITED STATES, THAT NEEDS TO
STOP TODAY.
>> YOU INTRODUCE LEGISLATION,
THE AMERICAN FOUNDING ACT OF
2020, SUPPORTING THE PRODUCTION
AND MICROELECTRONICS IN AMERICA,
THIS IS $14 BILLION THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AVAILABLE TO
DO THAT, WALK US THROUGH THE
LEGISLATION.
TOM: SEMI CONDUCTORS ARE
ESSENTIAL FOUNDATIONAL EVEN TO A
MODERN ECONOMY, NOT JUST
ADVANCED FIGHTER JETS BUT THE
BASIC ELECTRONICS IN OUR LIVES,
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON’T MAKE THAT
MANY IN THE UNITED STATES, THE
TRIPLE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE AS STOPPING AMERICAN
TECHNOLOGY GOING INTO CHINA BUT
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS
INCREASE THE PRODUCTIVE CAPACITY
OF OUR ECONOMY WHICH ARE
PROVIDING GOOD HIGH-PAYING JOBS
AS WELL IN THE SEMI CONDUCTOR
SECTOR.
THAT IS WHY I AND OTHER SENATORS
ARE WORKING ON LEGISLATION
HOPING TO PASS AS EARLY AS THIS
WEEK TO PROVIDE DIRECT SUPPORT
TO COMPANIES THAT WANT TO BRING
SEMICONDUCTOR MANUFACTURING BACK
TO THE UNITED STATES.
MARIA: DO YOU WANT THE U.S. TO
TAKE A STATE AND ERIC ERICKSON
OR NOKIA TO TELL THE WORLD THAT
THERE ARE WESTERN TELECOM
COMPANIES TO BE USED AWAY FROM
WALL WAKE?
TOM: THAT IS ONE POSSIBILITY,
THE PROBLEM IS THAT HUAWEI IS
NOT A PRIVATE COMPANY AS WE
IMAGINE, IT’S PART OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY, WHEN
THEY GO INTO A COUNTRY, THAT
COUNTRY KNOWS THEY HAVE THE FULL
BACKING OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, THEY ALSO GOING WITH
THREATS, THEY MIGHT TELL GERMANY
IF YOU DON’T USE WHAT WE
TECHNOLOGY THAT YOU CANNOT SELL
MERCEDES OR BMW’S IN CHINA, WHAT
NOKIA AND ERICSSON IN SOUTH
KOREA NEED IS THE SUPPORT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND OTHER WESTERN
COUNTRIES SO THEY CAN COMPETE ON
EQUAL TERMS, WHETHER THAT’S A
DIRECT STATE OR EXPORT FINANCING
OR ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE WOULD BE
TO PROVIDE AN OPEN RADIO ACCESS
NETWORK THAT WOULD PROVIDE SMALL
AND MEDIUM-SIZE COMPANIES
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BUSINESSES
AS WELL SO IT’S NOT DOMINATED BY
A HANDFUL OF TECH COMPANIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
WHAT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE HAVE
COMPETITIVE ALTERNATIVES TO
HUAWEI.
MARIA: LET ME SWITCH GEARS, WHEN
ASKED ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION, I
HAVE THIS REPORT AND COWAN AND
COMPANY TOLD ITS CLIENTS THAT IF
BIDEN WERE TO WIN, ELIZABETH
WARREN WILL BE THE KEY VOICE ON
ECONOMIC POLICY.
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON THAT
IN THE HOUSE APPROVING D.C.
STATEHOOD, SENATOR, THEY WANT TO
MAKE WASHINGTON, D.C. A STATE
INTO THOSE TWO ISSUES BECAUSE
THE AUDIENCE IS VERY INTERESTED
IN HEARING WHAT BIDEN IS DOING
AND IT’S EITHER TO BE TREASURY
SECRETARY, EVEN IF SHE’S NOT AT
ALL BE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC VOICE.
TOM: JOE BIDEN DOESN’T HAVE MUCH
OF AN AGENDA, HE’S HIDING IN HIS
BASEMENT, HE’S BEEN A
WEATHERVANE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS.
THAT’S WHY HE WAS SOFT ON
COMMUNISM, THE SOVIET UNION AND
VOTED TO OUTSOURCE OUR JOBS TO
CHINA WHILE HE STILL TO THIS DAY
IS NOT ONE OF OUR COMPETITORS.
THAT MEANS WHEN HE GETS IN
OFFICE, HE IS CIVILLY GOING TO
BE A VESSEL FOR THE RADICAL LEFT
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHETHER ELIZABETH WARREN
ECONOMIC POLICIES OR THE MOBS
THAT WE SEE IN THE STREETS
TEARING DOWN STATUTES AND
INSTANCE OF MOB VIOLENCE OR
PASSING D.C. STATEHOOD BILL.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS WANTED
WASHINGTON TO SEEK TO BE A
FEDERAL STATE, IT’S A CITY, NOT
A STATE.
IT’S A FEDERAL CITY BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO HAVE
CONTROL OF THE SEAT OF
GOVERNMENT.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS WERE
EXPERIENCED WITH THE WHAT YOU
COULD FACE IN PHILADELPHIA WERE
CONGRESS AT A TIME WITH MOB
VIOLENCE IN THE STREETS A FEW
WEEKS AGO, THAT’S WHY
WASHINGTON, D.C. NEEDS TO REMAIN
A FEDERAL CITY.
IN THE END WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
WANT IS NOT VOTING RIGHTS TO THE
RESIDENTS OF WASHINGTON, IF THEY
DID THAT THEY COULD RETURN IT TO
MARYLAND AS WE DID WITH THE
VIRGINIA SIDE IN 1840S, THEY
WANT TO DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
BECAUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAD
DENIED THEN CONTROL OF THE
GOVERNMENT FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
THIS --.
TOM: IS AN EXAMPLE WHAT JOE
BIDEN WILL DO.
YOU CAN GIVE THE RESIDENTIAL
PARTS OF WASHINGTON BACK TO
MARYLAND, IT WOULD GET THE OWN
HOUSE EAT BECAUSE IT’S A HOT
SIZE OF HOUSE DISTRICT AND
REPRESENTED BY THE MARYLAND
SENATORS.
IT WOULD NOT GET TO NEW
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS, THAT’S WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
MARIA: REAL QUICK ON ELIZABETH
WARREN, SHE PROPOSED A WEALTH
TAX AND SHE WANTS TO RAISE TAXES
AND SHE ALSO WANTS TO BREAK UP
COMPANIES AND TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES AND BANKS, IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND IF SHE IS THE KEY
ECONOMIC VOICE.
TOM: I THINK RONALD REAGAN’S
OLD-LINE WOULD APPLY TO SENATOR
WARREN AND OTHER DEMOCRATS AND
WOULDN’T BE INFLUENCING JOE
BIDEN.
IF IT MOVES, TAX IT, IF HE KEEPS
MOVING REGULATED, THEY DIE
SUBSIDIZE IT.